it's been about a decade since the last
financial crisis and yet this industry
has never been bigger legislation that
was meant to better regulate its largest
players has hurt smaller ones resulting
in most of the industry's assets to be
controlled by the top one percent they
become too big to fail I'm not referring
to big banks but the world of big
agriculture as a public health
practitioner who has worked with
small-scale farmers in Rwanda and now as
a small food business owner who sits at
the intersection between our consumers
and producers I've been exposed to one
of the most ecologically and
economically intensive industries in the
world and throughout my work I've
witnessed a chilling irony our farmers
who feed our communities cannot afford
the very foods they grow today a handful
of corporations continue to consolidate
the entire food supply chain from the
intellectual property of seeds to
produce the livestock all the way to the
financial institutions who lend to these
farmers and the recent results have been
rising bankruptcies for family farms and
little control for those who are just
trying to survive in the industry left
unchecked we will head into another
economic collapse one very similar to
the farm crisis of the 1980s when
commodity market prices crashed interest
rates doubled and many farmers lost
everything fortunately there is a very
simple three-part solution you can be
part of right now to help us transform
our food industry from the bottom up
step 1
shop at your local farmers markets
buying from your local market and
subscribing to a Community Supported
Agriculture produce box or better known
as a CSA may be the single greatest
purchasing decision you can make as a
consumer today last year American
farmers made the least they have in
almost three decades
because they now own fewer parts of the
supply chain than ever before under
exclusive contracts with big AG and
big-box stores farmers are not offered a
fair price for their goods in fact the
average farmer in America makes less
than 15 cents of every dollar on a
product that you purchase at a store on
the other hand farmers who sell their
goods at a farmers market
take home closer to 90 cents of every
dollar but beyond taking home a larger
share farmers use markets as an
opportunity to cultivate the next
generation of agriculturalists who
Shepherd our farmlands earn our pastures
in our fight against climate change we
need them now more than ever to promote
and preserve diverse land use when
multi-generational farms are lost to big
AG consolidation our communities suffer
in countless ways rural America has now
jumped above the national average in
violent crime three etta for farmworkers
surveyed have been directly impacted by
our opioid epidemic you know oftentimes
disguises accidents farmers suicide is
now on the rise step to shop at your
local farmers markets produce from a
large retail store is harvested before
it's ripe to travel more than a thousand
miles before ultimately sits on your
shelf roughly two weeks later
alternatively because most farmers
markets have proximity and production
requirements farmers travel less than 50
miles to offer you local produce with
minimal packaging raised with the advent
of online grocers and trending meal kits
consumers are increasingly disconnected
with their farmers and the economics of
food production since the rise of the
smartphone revolution directed consumer
goods have stagnated while local and
sustainable foods have been trending for
almost a decade terms like healthy and
natural have no legal framework in the
United States your best
for fresh nutrient-rich foods without
the marketing jargon go to your farmers
market buying local is not a new idea
but turning it into a habit in today's
world still is if we want to avoid the
high cost of cheap food protect our
environments rebuild our communities and
save our farmers literally we're going
to need to vote with our food purchases
the success of our food systems is
directly attached to us if we want to
break a big axe hold on our food supply
chain then we're going to need to
connect with our farmers we're going to
need to rebuild relationships with the
hands that feed us three times a day
plus two more for snacks with the
government online database of more than
eighty six hundred farmers markets
across the country you can easily find
the nearest one to you just think of
yourself as an investor in food or your
purchasing power helps create a more
equitable society for everyone Oh almost
forgot step three which may surprise you
shop at your local farmers markets thank
you
[Applause]